I think this is my third if not fourth
time at Hillsdale it's always such a
wonderful place to come visit and
ironically it's the place that forced me
to put a picture of Karl Marx on my
first slide and I've never done that
anywhere before so Hillsdale has that
distinction now um so they asked me to
to speak tonight on the topic of marks
and the continuing relevance of
socialism and this is part of the Great
Economist series that you have going
here
uh Unfortunately they asked me to speak
on someone who's not a great
Economist neither in his time nor ours
I'll say a little bit more about that
but then I'll spend more of my talk on
the subtitle that they gave me which is
on the continuing relevance of socialism
for us today and some things that we can
do about it I think that's more
productive than spending too much time
on Carl marks
um
so Marx when he was writing of course
he's most famously known the core
building block of his theory is the
labor theory of value now a lot of
people get worked up about this as any
Economist who knows history of thought
though they don't really fault Marx too
much about having a labor theory of
value because no Economist had a correct
theory of value at the time that Marx
was writing uh Adam Smith had something
like a labor or cost of production
theory of value every economist until
1871 had a flawed theory of value what
Marx was unique on is building from
there to the idea that that meant that
there was exploitation of Labor and the
ensuing social dynamics that he spins
out in his system uh where you can read
Smith today and excuse the flawed theory
of value and still get a lot of very
useful knowledge about how economic
systems work Marx when you take that
away a lot of the rest of it crumbles
away as does its relevance too and this
all happened in 1871 of course with
jeans and manger coming up with the
marginal theory of value that value is
about the marginal you the the valuation
is about the use of the marginal unit to
the subjective Chooser
um so I'll pause here before the marks
today and think about how about Marx
during his time Economist before his
death had already realized that the
system was flawed there were normal uh
critique there were many critiques of it
made but most of mainstream economics
wasn't paying a whole lot of attention
to Marks by the turn of the 20th century
uh Bomar of course a great Austrian
Economist had wrote uh on on Marx in the
close of his system um but Marx was
dead literally and kind of figuratively
in economics by the early 20th century
so why would someone whose theories were
no longer really relevant be resurrected
and widely cited and continue to be so
today and there was a paper published
this past year uh by a friend of mine
Phil Magnus and a former student of mine
Mike movi who's a professor up at
Northwood University here in Michigan uh
called the mainstreaming of Marx and
they said what explains Marx's influence
and you see two lines on this chart here
the the dark solid line is basically
citations to Marx's work dating from
times during Marx's life up through the
early 1930s on the far right of that and
the dotted line is what we can call fake
marks this is a weighted average of
other social scientists and thinkers
during this time whose citation pattern
when weighted together
nearly accurately mimics marks right up
until
1917 this is something called synthetic
control analysis that we use in
economics it's an empirical type of
technique basically when you want to
counterfactual to evaluate the real
thing against it's a way to create an
weighted average of other things like it
that mirror it so you've got your so
think of it as North and South Korea
that's a natural experiment in the world
we don't get lots of those where you can
hold almost all else constant and
compare it to the
alternative synthetic control gives you
a fake version of North and South Korea
where one's the real one and the fake
one is a weighted average that performs
exactly like it right up until we free
it and then we free it and we say hey
what happens do they continue to act
alike after this or do they act
differently and in this case 1917 of
course the date of the Russian
Revolution is chosen and what happens
there the real marks and fake marks
citations deser
diverge quite
severely did all of a sudden
someone realized that Marx's writing was
correct after all that mainstream
economics had been incorrectly ignoring
him of course not we know it was the
Russian Revolution and the political
relevance of Marx to the Soviet project
brought worldwide attention to it and
people started citing Marx much
more that is the major message of This
research paper that they did is Marx's
relevance isn't about the internal
coherence of the ideas the relevance of
the ideas it's about the violent
revolution that made them politically
relevant that forced other social
science or I don't know about forced but
encouraged other social scientist to
start talking about marks a lot more and
this is something that continues to this
day now I was trained as an
economist I guess it was 20 years ago I
got my PhD when I was starting my
studies Mar Marx was kind of dead then
we weren't wasn't something we were
thinking about we had just come off the
1990s in fact what some economists have
called the Agee of Milton
fredman where we can look and see what's
happening in the globe the left uh the
for you the left graph shows global
economic freedom from 1980 through
2010 and you see a major increase
particularly during the ne decade of the
90s as the Soviet Union collapses
Eastern block becomes freed they start
moving more towards markets capitalism
and more liberal democracy
in fact I just came uh a couple days ago
from The Mont Pellerin Society meetings
in bre and Woods New Hampshire uh and I
was struck I was reading uh some
speeches given by Ed fuler uh who was
treasur of the Mont Pellerin Society uh
twice before me uh and he is president
in the mid 90s it was a series of
speeches he's gave and I was struck by
how triumphant the views of Mont
Pellerin Society members were at that
time of the retreat
of socialism the rise of global Freedom
at that time and it was shortly
thereafter that I was earning my PhD and
Marx wasn't really on the the radar
screen uh unfortunately that started to
change not too long ago the the graph on
the now of course he was still cited but
it was like by crazy cat ladies uh by
the way there seriously was a book
published this year called marks for
cats by Duke University press I kid you
not I kid you not
uh the the figure on the right is more
Zoomed In from 2000 I think to to 2020
of economic freedom that continued to
grow globally now it's it's zoomed in so
that's why the line's a lot steeper
there continued to kind of inch up the
real the the big gains were in the 1990s
but continued to inch up during the the
2000s until we get the Great Recession
then you get a retreating global
economic freedom and a general crisis of
belief in capitalism not notice not a
crisis of capitalism this was the house
that Uncle Sam built that we experienced
not free markets uh however it shook
people's beliefs in capitalism and they
started looking more towards
Alternatives including the legacy of KL
Marx and
socialism um and then of course by the
way what you see at the very end of that
graph is the the drop in economic
freedom during the the pandemic which is
by far the biggest drop in economic
freedom any of us have experienced in
our lifetime but this is measured by the
economic freedom of the world index
which actually doesn't include covid
restrictions so mostly what you're
picking up there is restrictions on
foreign travel and government stimulus
spending that are causing the biggest
drop that you can see in its Trend uh in
fact I should mention with a Hills Jail
grad who's a current PhD student at
Texas Tech with me uh Vince maazi uh he
and I have a series of papers where we
try to adjust measures of economic
freedom during the pandemic to account
across countries for all of the pandemic
restrictions and it shows a much bigger
drop obviously uh in economic freedom
than what you see there uh so what is
happening with the ideas of Marx during
the same time so this is that same graph
that you had before with fake marks and
real marks fake marks being that bottom
line real marks being the top one it
keeps growing growing and growing that
Divergence over time the thing that was
cited like marks before continues to be
a
muddling socialist actually it's about
93% I think the weed average was was
socialist thinkers in the in the Marx
algorithm uh of mostly irrelevance Marx
continues to grow but notice the big
down spot that you see there that's the
1990s where Marx is going away and he
kind of starts creeping back up during
the 2000s and really starts taking off
after the housing crisis this is Mark's
becoming more relevant today and if you
don't think citations and scholly
sources are a good version of this let's
go to the ultimate scholly source
Twitter and that eminent scholar Michael
Moore who says most polls now show young
adults Across America prefer socialism
which he equates with fairness to
capitalism which he calls
selfishness Ed
more is not alone on
Twitter so socialism is back by the
mid2 so victims of communist Memorial
Foundation survey of younger people
found they asked them what's your
favorite economic system 44% said
socialism 7% said communism only 42%
said
capitalism they viewed capitalism as
something failing post the housing
crisis young Democrats socialists of
America chapters start springing up on
University campuses across the
country I didn't check but I assume
Hillsdale doesn't have
one and one of the chapter President
says I think people in my gener
generation people who grew up post Cold
War I don't think socialism is much as a
Scarlet S as it is for older folks the
taboo for me was never
there this seems to be a common thing
among younger people now of course the
New York Times also in 2017 ran a red
Century column one column every week for
52 weeks dedicated to the history of
socialism to celebrate the 100th
anniversary of the Russian
Revolution 52 columns
under five mentioned the economic
stagnation of the Soviet Union or other
socialist systems only a handful
mentioned any of the human atrocities I
think three of them were on Stalin one
of ma lenon like always seems to get a
pass even though he did everything evil
that Stalin did just on a smaller scale
because he had a stroke when he was 55
years old and couldn't do it for
longer Instead The New York Times gave
us columns like why women had better sex
under
socialism which if true how we wait this
against tens of millions of dead bodies
and think that deserves one out of the
52 weeks I am not sure other columns
like Lenin's Eco Warriors for land being
set aside versus the actual
environmental record of the Soviet Union
were
featured this is creating a
misperception about the functioning and
history of socialist systems that were
taken up in the name of Marx
then of course we've got politicians
Like Bernie Sanders running around
confusing things and saying he means
socialism like countries like Denmark
like Sweden like Norway which by the way
to be fair it's not just Looney left
that says things like this about the
Scandinavian countries I've spent a fair
bit of time on Fox News and I've been on
with guests who will say socialist
Sweden because they don't like taxes
we'll get back to this in a second but
both the right and the left
mischaracterize Scandinavian countries
and I had a when I was making these
slides I put AOC in there and I just put
a placeholder in insert crazy quote
here I I decided it was better to just
leave it like that and you could you
could pick your own
so the these disturbing Trends are what
my my co-author and good friend Bob
Lawson and I were observing in the mid-
teens and said uh rather than being our
normal Egghead academic selves and
writing another Journal article that
three people will read why don't we try
to do a different project and reach a
wider audience about the actual
functioning uh and practice of socialist
economic systems so we wrote the book
that was mentioned in my introduction
socialism sucks two economists drink
their way through the unfree World which
is an Anthony Bourdain style firstperson
travel book but replace food with the
economics and history of socialist
systems and the subtitle accurately
describes how Bob and I spend our time
when we're doing this and in fact
actually the alcohol becomes a metaphor
for for the functioning of the economies
uh as as we go through around the world
um so this is not a book talk uh it's a
talk about the continuing relevance of
socialism but I'm going to look at some
of the ideas I learned about socialism
while doing this book from young people
in the United States today and say what
do our travels have to inform the ideas
that these young people were having
about socialism so our tour went from
Sweden to Venezuela to Cuba to Korea to
China Russia Ukraine Georgia
and we ended back in the USSA at the
largest socialist gathering in the
United States of course celebrated in
Chicago over the 4th of July not exactly
how I usually like to spend my
Independence Day holiday so let's
actually start at the back then and say
what were these kids
thinking
maybe there we go all right
so by the way attending this conference
was quite different there's absolutely
nobody dressed like
this there were no blue BL Blazers
actually including Among Us uh Bob who's
a native of Cincinnati War a Cincinnati
Reds cap which I don't think anybody got
the joke when we were there
uh but we weren't there to argue with
these kids or even educate them we were
there for research I wanted to find out
what were they thinking what is it that
brings all of them there to this
conference and when I say no one looked
like this I didn't really need to show
you my clothes I could have just done
this because there's basically no
middle-aged people at this conference so
I uh a few years ago I was around 40 Bob
was around 50 uh there was nobody in
that age group uh basically everybody
was 35 and younger young people
attracted to Socialism or over 70 who
were ex hippies from the 1960s and still
hanging out at socialist Gatherings that
that was the
crowd